ready nice okay I like I said I look
like I'm just with the bottle I say yes
[Music]
I'm here with mamrie Hart kind of heart
you don't know there I'm gonna be really
fun today to do a little bit of a
challenge a little bit of a witch friend
knows me better challenge I do like the
[ __ ] oh yeah no swatching all right get
it out I have ten questions for you guys
and you up some paper in front of you
I'll ask a question you guys break down
their answer and then we'll see who got
it right or wrong we're called spies
[ __ ] have Sharpie I gave s is one
better than the other
yeah sharpie you can see some things
that aren't as seen are more important
go on yeah okay here we go first
question what is my middle name
and how do you spell it let me know when
you're set set I'm set okay memory
what's your answer and no II
I said an e it's what's number two what
comments did I go to
yeah cool I said Harvard Wow wrong
looking correct ah ass kissing Thank You
college and you gave the 2015
commencement speech 101 here we go
what's number three what is my mom's
first and last name I wouldn't know this
for you guys numeric me or our baby you
know my mom's maiden name yes you know
the main name isn't the first married
name Andrew what's your answer said mrs.
Teresa wife of Bill I said Teresa Jones
okay I mean that may be her witness
prediction you know I'm a bleep fan out
okay still one-to-one next question what
was my dog deuces original name yeah I
forget about it sometimes too I can give
you guys a clue please please
mythical creature I mean this doesn't
define her friend okay yep Hannah
dranzer Dixie Dixie okay I'm close
ma'am I'm cute wildebeest Mazel I mean
combine those two things and you get the
actual name um Phoenix
Willoughby's now that's a good time for
me more like a sci-fi strip club
literally I've been preparing small
fears okay next question it's still
one-on-one what year did I move to Los
Angeles everywhere answer October 2011
incorrect Hannah what's your answer fo
2012 you have what was that you go one
and a half to two points right now okay
we do question like what's your oh yeah
linear an earlier when oh yeah if you
know yeah sure yeah if you know my
animal year in the what is it Chinese
sodium then you'll get a bonus point I
think it's this a note your answer Libra
[Music]
you also get two points so now in boiler
to three-and-a-half how many subscribers
can I have on my youtube channel right
now and this is like the closest to not
going over okay it is close okay and
this will hopefully change in a good way
by the time I end it are we doing like
chillin I do um I need four numbers okay
neighbor what's your answer to point
nine seven four million Hannah
I put three point two five zero Oh
memories closer
zero to three
okay there is a point at least four
point five to four how many episodes of
my podcast not too deep are there in
total at this current moment right so
fast
whoever gets closest you can go over
whoever gets closest I'm guessing okay
maybe what's your answer 122 okay Hanna
what's your answer
86 and this is estimated by your ear
from Jack we're about five to four and a
half I'll give it you
how many piercings do I have don't look
at me
six okay yeah what's your answer three
okay man returns for correct answers -
oh just your you just a minute well
because this is - but mine and all - oh
that's me better aim three chain
restaurants that I have worked okay here
we go
okay I know one you know them all Hannah
what are your answers Bobby's correct
cheesecake incorrect T Jennifer that's
also incorrect and - Jake was like the
epitome like I didn't get that one so
you got Warren okay so let's see if
memory can be chilly correct
Houston's yeah correct that's why police
are wise you since it's a chain there's
one that I was younger group and do the
Buster's that's correct
I would also have accepted Anneliese at
the B's Chili's Olive Garden right yes
thank you guys so much for watching I
don't have a gift for you make sure and
check out how this channel because we
made a bunch of videos over there
channels channels we made really fun
videos over there horrible yes you smelt
it correctly okay took it away so I
spelled it correctly counted that in a
metaphor